[Musique]
les rues de dijon à l'heure des repas
maintenant c'est sam un ballet incessant
de cyclistes avec un sac isotherme sur
le dos l'arrivée des sites internet et
applications mobiles fait des livres ou
ait eu bris à modifier les habitudes
avec pour chacun une cinquantaine de
restaurants proposé en catalogue en à
peine un an la livraison de repas à vélo
s'est imposé dans les moeurs quotidienne
de dijonnais un service en plein pic
12h30 dans ce restaurant de bagel une
commode est en préparation
le client n'est pas sur place mais chez
lui c'est un coursier qui vient
récupérer la commande depuis
l'apparition de ces nouveaux livreur le
chiffre d'affaires a ici sensiblement
augmenté nous ça nous a fait à peu près
entre 10 et 15 % sur une année déjà pour
certains restaurateurs fameux m 25 % de
plus
reste que le service à un coût pour
rémunérer le coursier et dégager leurs
marges les opérateurs qui mettent en
relation restaurateurs et clients
demandent 30 % du prix de la commande
ça veut dire que vous c'est 30% voulait
répercuter automatiquement sur le prix
de vente d'autres restaurateurs soit 6 e
de diminuer leurs marges et partage de
coûts du service avec le client à voir
le nombre de livraisons réalisées à
dijon le coup n'est pas un problème pour
les consommateurs mode est devenue une
adepte
elle se fait livrer une fois par semaine
bonsoir
ça me permet de ne pas me déplacer un
peu la technique du feignants et non
mais je le paye parce que je me dis pas
ça fait passer les jeunes et puis bon ça
arrive tout frais 1 apporte pas besoin
de déplacer une pratique ça vous fait
combien sur la commande en sur coup sûr
vous dire que maintenant je sais pas en
totale j'ai pris un menu normal plus en
leur coeur et ça me fait 17 euros soit
environ 4 euros de plus que si elle a
défait elle même le km qui la séparent
du restaurant le travail à mehdi pas du
tout
mais même moi c'était manier les commet
ce genre de tournoi
19h07 fois devant le mcdonald's de la
rue piétonne depuis l'accord passé par
le fast food a vécu le ritz c'est un peu
le poids de ralliement je vais encore
travail aux gens du coin des cas une
commande concernant arthur ici à
beaucoup de comment une croissance avait
atteint jusqu'à des grosses commandes
mais ici il ya des petites communes team
envie de quoi il ya beaucoup de
commandes pour ça on est beaucoup pour
chaque course de réaliser le livreur
touche au moins 5 euros entre 900 et
moi je fais entre ce qu'on s'en sont
tenus le soir c'est plus avantageux
d'avoir aidé des jeunes comme eux il y
en a entre 200 et 300 sur
l'agglomération
ils sont micro entrepreneurs utilisent
leur propre vélo et leur smartphone si
certaines voix dénoncent un retour du
travail payé à la tâche
le voit l'opportunité d'augmenter leurs
revenus avec en plus une certaine
liberté
demain j'ai pas envie de travailler je
travaille pas dommage on y travaille et
je travaille je prévois mais semaine
d'une semaine sur l'autre c'est à dire
que j'ai là par exemple j'ai jusqu'à
vendredi midi pour m'inscrire sur les
créneaux de la semaine prochaine et si
j'ai pas envie de bosser la semaine
prochaine je n'aspire pas en seulement
quelques mois ce nouveau service a
révolutionné le secteur de la
restauration et sa croissance est loin
d'être à son terme avec la prochaine
coupe du monde de football
le nombre de livraisons devraient
atteindre des records